the geo-barrants arriving in Bari
accompanied by Coast Guard and police
boats
yes
[Music]
it's tumultuous Journey ending in the
calm Waters of port
on the decks a mood of excitement and
anticipation on your face cover your
nose and your mouth
among the 606 people rescued from the
Mediterranean Sea the first people off
the very young and also the sick and the
injured
and this is how they were saved we
joined rescue boats rushing to a wildly
overcrowded fishing boat drifting in the
Mediterranean its Captain had abandoned
The Vessel water and food had run out
many aboard thought they were going to
die
instead they found themselves rescued
and brought here to Italy to Europe
the Geo balance is run by the charity
medicine Frontier which says it has a
duty to help people in distress so for
me it's not the length of time
privilege of being
when they are experiencing a terrible
moment in their lives but also that
moment of hope that I am able to see
particularly during these rescues
but then things slow down disembarking
hundreds of migrants is a painstaking
process that stretches on for hours and
people get Restless
the response is creative Simon and nurse
from Belgium produces his trumpet
and the mood lightens laughter creates
calm
waiting in the crowd is Handy an
Egyptian who we met after the rescue
with ambitions to become a footballer
at last he is summoned to go ashore
film as usual will welcome I feel like
I'm home
whether you think these people are
Asylum Seekers or refugees or economic
migrants doesn't matter because what
we've seen on this journey is a profound
truth that desperate people will go
through extraordinary dangerous lengths
if they think it will improve their
lives and that is at the very heart of
migration
candy like everyone else now faces the
scrutiny of the authorities in Italy a
country where the government is trying
to reign in migration
his future is uncertain but for the
moment he's simply happy to have reached
Europe
Adam Parson Sky News Barry